hello and welcome to math simplified
in this video we will discuss about
fungal infection of the nails
known as tiniangium or onychomycosis
toenails or fingernails both can be
affected but toenail infection is more
common
we will talk about the fungi that cause
this infection
how you get infected and how you can
prevent such
infections and in the end we will also
discuss how to treat the fungal
infections of the nails
hi i'm dr umar malik and let's begin
onychomycosis or tiniangium is very
common
and it is estimated that about 7 to 10
percent of adults suffer from these
infections
although these infections are generally
harmless and do not cause
any serious problems but they can cause
a decrease in quality of life
and self-confidence as these can distort
the nails giving them
a very ugly appearance fungal nail
infections can cause the nails to become
discolored thick and more likely to
crack and break
that is why it is important to treat
them at an early stage
because if not treated in the early
stages it becomes very difficult to
manage
as the topical drugs that are used for
the treatment of normal
infections of the skin cannot penetrate
the nail
special types of medicines are used for
advanced mycomycosis which we will
discuss later in this video
now let's first talk about the fungi
that cause these fungal infections of
the nails and how you get infected
these fungal nail infections occur from
the overgrowth of fungi
in under or on the nail fungi thrive
in warm moist environments so this type
of environment can
cause them to naturally overpopulate the
same fungi that cause
jock itch athlete's foot and ring worm
can cause
nail infections these belong to a group
of fungi that is known as dermatophytes
trichophyton rubrum is the most common
dermatophyte that is involved in
onychomycosis
other dermatophytes that may be involved
are trichophyton interdigital
epidermophyten trichophyton violation
and microsporum
fungi that are present in or on your
body
can cause these nail infections if you
come in contact with someone else who
has fungal infections
you may contract it as well you can also
get these infections if you walk
barefooted excessively or come in
contact with soil or water often
you are more likely to develop a fungal
nail infection if you have diabetes or
aged above 65 if you have a heart
disease that causes poor circulation
if you swim in a public swimming pool
you are also more likely to develop
fungal infections
if you have a nail injury or have a skin
injury around the nail
if you have moist fingers or toes for an
extended time
if you have a weakened immune system or
if you wear closed tight shoes such as
tennis shoes or boots for extended
periods of time
now let's talk about how onychomycosis
presents and what symptoms you can
develop
a fungal infection of the nail may
affect only a part of the nail
the entire nail or several nails common
signs of a fungal nail infection include
a distorted nail that may lift off from
the nail bed
an odour coming from the infected nail
brittle or
thickened nail you can also develop a
dark colored nail
caused by debris building up under your
nail
nail fungal infection usually begins as
a white or yellow spot under the tip of
your fingernail or toenail
as the fungal infection goes deeper nail
fungus may cause your nail to discolor
thicken and crumble at the edge and it
can affect several nails
if you visit a dermatologist they can
confirm the diagnosis by performing a
few simple tests
nail clippings or scrapings are taken
and are observed under the microscope
if fungi are detected then the diagnosis
can be confirmed
also a culture can be done for detecting
the fungi
now let's look at how to treat these
fungal infections of the nails
the mainstream of treatment are
anti-fungal drugs either taken orally or
applied directly on the nails
the treatment of fungal infections of
the nails usually takes a couple of
months or maybe even up to an year
because it is very hard for these
anti-fungal drugs to penetrate the nail
plate
these antifungals include drugs like
etraconazole
aphenachonazole tobinafine
cyclopedoxolamine and
amarolphine if you only have a
superficial or mild infection of the
nails which looks
something like this you can only apply
the topical drugs like
anti-fungal creams lotions or lacquers
and skip oral antifungal medicines but
if you have an extensive
involvement of the nails or if your
nails look something like this
you need to take oral anti-fungal
medicines
now nail paints containing
cyclopyroxolamine and amarolphine
are most commonly used as the first line
of treatment
cyclopirox comes as a solution to apply
to the nails and skin
immediately surrounding the nails it is
usually applied
once daily usually around bedtime
cyclopedox topical solution will work
best if you trim your nails regularly
during your treatment
you should remove all loose nail or nail
material using a nail clipper
or nail file before you begin treatment
and
every week during your treatment only
apply cyclopirox topical solution to
your nails and the skin
under and around your nails be careful
not to get the solution on any other
areas of the skin or parts of the body
especially in or near your eyes nose and
mouth
the most important point to remember
during this treatment is to continue
using this nail paint for at least
six months to one year to have a
complete cure and prevent recurrences
amarolphine nail paint is also used in a
similar way and duration
but studies have shown that
cycloperoxolamine is more effective than
amarolphine
but the results can vary depending upon
the patient
aphenachonuzole a new antifungal drug is
an emerging therapy for the topical
treatment of onychomycosis
it comes in a 10 solution that can
penetrate easily through the nail plate
and
even through nail polish for a complete
cure
8 to 12 months of daily application of
this solution is recommended
so these were some effective topical
drugs for the fungal
infection of the nails now if you have
multiple
nail involvement or if your nails look
something like this
you need to take oral antifungal
medicines
oral therapies have high cure rates for
onychomycosis
the most commonly used oral drugs for
the treatment of onychomycosis
are gryzopholine terbinafine
etraconazole
and ketoconazole tabinofine in the
dosage of 250 milligrams per day
is taken daily for eight weeks for
fingernail fungus
and twelve weeks for toenail fungus
uteroconazole is considered to be the
most effective oral antifungal drug for
the treatment of nail fungal infections
the dosage of atrocious oil is 200
milligram once daily
taken continuously for six to twelve
weeks
intraconozole is also prescribed in
pulsed doses
pulse treatment consists of 200
milligram taken two times in a day
for one week per month and this is
continued for two to three months for
fingernails
and three to four months for toenails
please note that i cannot prescribe
these oral antifungal drugs over a video
because
they can also cause side effects so it
is always advice that you consult a
dermatologist or a physician if you want
to start these medicines
side effects of these medicines include
headache diarrhea
skin rash or elevated liver enzymes
which are important to monitor
now fungal infections of the nails are
also associated with fungal infections
of
feed also known as linear pedis and
fungal infection
that occurs between the toes known as
athlete's foot
i am going to make separate videos about
these topics so make sure to subscribe
to our channel so that you get notified
so friends this was all about fungal
infection of the nails i hope you find
the video helpful
make sure to share this video with your
friends family or anyone you know who is
having this condition
you can support us by joining our
channel here on youtube or becoming a
member of our patreon page
where you get patreon only exclusive
features thank you so much for watching
see you in the next video